>> SO, OUR GENIUSES IN
WASHINGTON SP-PT 20 YEARS IN
AFGHANISTAN WITH NO CLEARLY
DEFIND MISSION.
THEN THEY DECIDED TO PICK A
COLLEGE PROFESSOR TO RUN THE
COUNTRY, RUN AFGHANISTAN, A GUY
LIKE HIM EVERY BIT AS CORRUPT AS
THEY ARE IN THE END.
THEN THEY GET AN END TO
CALCULATE AND HUMILIATE THE
UNITED STATES.
MOST DISASTROUS EXIT IN 250
YEARS.
HOW CAN WE MAKE THIS WORST?
I KNOW, LET'S IMPORT RAPISTS.
THAT MAKES IT WORST THAN WE HAVE
MADE IT.
THEY.
HAVE WASHINGTON TIMES HAS
REPORTED A PREVIOUSLY REPORTED
RAPIST HAS LANDED AT DULLES
AIRPORT IN WASHINGTON.
-- TWO THOUSAND AFGHANI VAC
AOUYS ARE BEING HELD.
HE HASN'T SEEN A SINGLE SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDER.
ALL EVACUEES WERE FREE TO LEAVE
THE BASE WHEN THEY WANTED TO.
CONGRESSMAN TIFFANY JOINS US
TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON.
THANK YOU FOR SEEING THIS
YOURSELF.
TELL US WHAT YOU SAW.
>> SO WE HAVE SEEN THE DEBACLE
IN AD BEGAN STAN.
IT APPEARS THE BOYD EN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOUBLING DOWN
BRINGING PEOPLE UNVETTED INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
I WAS AT FORT McCOY LAST
FRIDAY.
TWO THOUSAND EVACUEES FROM
AFGHANISTAN WERE THERE.
WE FOUND NONE WERE THERE ON A
SPECIAL IMMIGRATION VISA.
THEY WERE ALL THERE ON PAROLE.
FOR OUR LISTENERS A SPECIAL
IMMIGRATION VISA IS A THOROUGH
VETTING PROCESS THAT TAKES UP
TWO YEARS.
THE PAROLE AUTHORITY IS GRANTED
TO THE SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOME LAND
SECURITY.
HE CAN JUST WAVE PEOPLE IN.
THEY HAVE CIRCUMVENTED THE SIV
PROCESS.
THEY'RE JUST BRINGING PEOPLE IN
ON PAROLE.
THE SECOND THING, TUCKER, PEOPLE
COULD LEAVE THE BASE INCLUDED
WITHOUT THE AUTHORITY OF THE
GENERAL THAT IS OVERSEEING FORT
McCOY.
>> SO WE HAVE TO ISLANDS OFF THE
COAST.
NAN TUCKET AND MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
I DON'T THINKY OF THESE REFUGES
HAVE BEEN MOVED THERE.
THEY HAVE BEEN MOVED TO
WISCONSIN, MAINE.
FAR FROM THE CENTERS OF POWER.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
CHANGE THAT.
WHY AREN'T WE MOVING THEM TO THE
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE MAKE THE
DECISIONS LIVE?
>> THAT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA.
WHAT I HAVE SUGGESTED.
THERE ARE AFGHANS THAT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO COME INTO OUR COUNTRY.
I HAVE TALKED TO SERVICE MEN IN
MY DISTRICT WHO SAY THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE ABLE TO
COME FROM AFGHANISTAN.
SOME OF THEM HAVE GIVEN ALMOST
THEIR LIVES BEING THREATENED BY
THE TALIBAN.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER THEY'RE NOT BEING VETTED
THOROUGHLY.
THEY SHOULD GO TO A THIRD, A
SAFE THIRD COUNTRY LIGHT CUTTER
OR SOMEPLACE LIKE THAT AND
VETTED THERE.
IF THEY GET THROUGH THE VETTING
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME IN.
84% OF THE PEOPLE THAT IN THE
FIRST QUARTER OF THIS YEAR THAT
TRIED TO GET AN SIV IN
AFGHANISTAN, THEY WERE REJECTED.
ONLY 16% WERE ABLE TO GET IN.
THIS HAS TO BE A THOROUGH
VETTING PROCESS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
CIRCUM VETTING IT.
>> THEY'RE USING A CRISIS TO
CHANGE THE COUNTRY.
THEY WIL